From WBEZ Chicago, it's a special Christmas edition of This American Life . We have a bunch of things for you today, including later in the program, "Christmas on Fire." But let's just kick things off right now with a song recorded at an event we did onstage a few weeks ago.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》圣诞特别版节目。今天我们要为大家呈现许多精彩内容，包括节目后半段的“圣诞着火了”。但让我们先从几周前我们在舞台上录制的一首歌开始吧。
(SINGING) On the 12th day of Christmas, my true love gave to me 12 drummers drumming, 11 pipers piping, 10 lords a leaping, nine ladies dancing, eight maids a milking, seven swans a swimming, six geese a laying, five golden rings, four calling birds, three French hens, two turtle doves, and a partridge in a pear tree.
（歌唱）圣诞节第12天，我的真爱送我：12个击鼓的鼓手，11个吹笛的风笛手，10个跳跃的领主，9个跳舞的女士，8个挤奶的女佣，7个游泳的天鹅，6个下蛋的鹅，5个金戒指，4个鸣叫的鸟，3个法国母鸡，2个斑鸠，以及梨树上的一只鹧鸪。
I have always hated that song.
我一直很讨厌这首歌。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
[观众笑声]
I have always hated that song. I feel like that song is symbolic of everything that is bad about Christmas. I should say I have no bad feelings about Christmas. I am a noncombatant when it comes to Christmas.
我一直很讨厌这首歌。我觉得这首歌象征着圣诞节所有糟糕的东西。我得说，我对圣诞节没什么恶感。说到圣诞节，我算是个非战斗人员。
I was onstage talking about this song because we had this idea that we thought might make a really fun thing to try for Christmas. And that is we organized a night of improv comedy. And I know maybe you're saying, OK, how does that go together? Why improv comedy and Christmas?
我在舞台上谈论这首歌，是因为我们有个想法，觉得这可能是圣诞节尝试的一件非常有趣的事情。我们组织了一场即兴喜剧之夜。我知道，你可能会说，好的，这有什么关联？为什么是即兴喜剧和圣诞节？
OK, well, this is going to take a little explaining. Stay with me. This British writer and performer named Daniel Kitson-- I saw him say this thing about Christmas that seems so true. He says that when you're a kid and you wake up Christmas morning, what makes Christmas feel so magical is this feeling of, like, "Oh, my god. It's going to be amazing. The world is so full of possibility. Anything can happen." The fact that Santa Claus even exists, this literally magical being who came to your home.
好吧，这需要一点解释。听我慢慢道来。这位英国作家兼表演者丹尼尔·基特森（Daniel Kitson）——我曾看他讲过一件事，关于圣诞节的，似乎非常有道理。他说，当你还是个孩子，圣诞节早上醒来，让圣诞节感觉如此神奇的，是这种感觉，就像，“天哪，这太棒了。世界充满了无限可能。任何事情都可能发生。”圣诞老人的存在，这个实际上神奇的存在，来到你家，这一事实。
And Kitson says this thrilled feeling that anything can happen, that is the thing that is so hard to hold onto once we become adults. And in fact, he says that so many adults at Christmas, they try to recreate the same Christmas year after year with the same everything over and over and over. It's like they lock in. Christmas becomes the opposite of "anything can happen." That is why it never feels as magical to adults. But it is possible to get back to that feeling.
基特森说，这种觉得什么都可能发生的激动感，是我们成年后最难保持的东西。事实上，他说很多成年人在圣诞节时，试图年复一年地重现同一个圣诞节，重复着同样的一切。这就像他们被锁定住了。圣诞节变成了“任何事情都可能发生”的反面。这就是为什么成年人从不觉得它那么神奇。但要找回那种感觉是有可能的。
And, OK, back to the plan for today's show. One place that adults embrace that feeling that anything could happen and it's going to happen and then they make it happen is improv comedy, where, you know, they walk on stage with no idea what anybody is going to say. And then one person tries something. They say something. And then somebody else pitches in with a line of their own, and then somebody else pitches in. And before you know it, they've made like a whole scene, a whole world, really.
好了，回到今天节目的计划。成年人拥抱那种“任何事情都可能发生，而且即将发生，然后他们让它发生”的感觉的地方，就是即兴喜剧。他们走上舞台，完全不知道别人会说什么。然后一个人尝试做点什么，说点什么。接着另一个人加入一句自己的台词，然后又有人加入。在你意识到之前，他们已经创造出了一整个场景，一整个世界。
And so with that in mind, we got these incredible improv comedians, and we got a club to perform in, and we did a show. And we did the show in this particular style of improv, where the people on stage, they tell true stories about their lives. And then those stories, those true stories, become the basis of the improv scenes that they then invent. And those scenes lead them to other true stories that then lead them into other improv scenes and so on and so on and so on.
考虑到这一点，我们请来了这些出色的即兴喜剧演员，找了一个演出俱乐部，做了一场秀。我们以这种特殊的即兴风格表演，舞台上的人讲述他们生活中的真实故事。然后这些故事，这些真实的故事，成为他们随后发明的即兴表演场景的基础。而那些场景引导他们走向其他真实故事，进而带入更多的即兴场景，如此循环往复。
And I was there. I kicked things off with a story about that song, about the song "The 12 Days of Christmas," which is a song that I noticed, even though-- just to say it again-- Christmas is not my day.
当时我在现场。我先讲了一个关于那首歌的故事，关于《圣诞节的12天》这首歌。我注意到，尽管——再次声明——圣诞节不是我的节日。
I am not somebody who celebrates Christmas at all. I'm a Jew. And I'm not that kind of Jew whose parents celebrated Christmas on Hanukkah. We were pure Hanukkah people, and we look down on the Christmas Hanukkah Jews.
我根本不是一个庆祝圣诞节的人。我是犹太人。我也不是那种父母会过光明节同时过圣诞节的犹太人。我们是纯正的光明节人士，我们瞧不起那些过圣诞节的光明节犹太人。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
[观众笑声]
And in fact, I grew up in a suburb of Baltimore that was so Jewish, I didn't understand that we were in the minority. And so Christmas, I do nothing. It means nothing to me. The day means nothing. And most years, I go to Vegas on Christmas.
事实上，我在巴尔的摩郊区长大，那里犹太人非常多，我甚至没意识到我们是少数派。所以圣诞节，我什么都不做。它对我来说毫无意义。这一天什么也不是。大多数年份，我在圣诞节时会去拉斯维加斯。
But I do really love Christmas music. I've always loved Christmas music. And at some point in my 20s, I started to make a collection of Christmas CDs and records. And the worst song of all is the song "The 12 Days of Christmas." And whenever it comes on, I just think, like, why is this still in circulation? First of all, the words refer to a wife and a world that none of us can relate to or care about. "12 lords a leaping," like, what is-- what experience is that even referring to? And then swans are swimming, geese are laying. So are we in a warm climate, a cold climate? It just raises so many questions.
但我真的很喜欢圣诞音乐。我一直很喜欢圣诞音乐。在我20多岁的时候，我开始收集圣诞CD和唱片。所有歌曲中最糟糕的就是《圣诞节的12天》。每当它响起，我就想，为什么这首歌还在流传？首先，歌词指的是一个我们谁都无法共鸣或不在乎的妻子和一个世界。“10个跳跃的领主”，这到底指的是什么体验？还有游泳的天鹅，下蛋的鹅。所以我们是在温暖的气候还是寒冷的气候？这引发了太多问题。
But also the form of the song is so intensely boring. And you guys know what I'm talking about, where you do the first one, and then you go back and you do all the ones before it, which you already did. You know I mean? So you do two turtle doves and a partridge in a pear tree. Then three French hens, two turtle doves, and a partridge in a pear tree. Then four calling birds, three French hens, two turtle doves and a partridge in a pear tree. Five golden rings, four calling birds. And so like-- and so you know what's going to happen. It's repetitious in the most boring way, and then it's always sung very slowly, which is annoying.
而且这首歌的形式极其枯燥。你们知道我在说什么，先唱第一句，然后倒回去唱之前的所有歌词，而那些你已经唱过了。你懂我的意思吗？所以你唱2个斑鸠和1只梨树上的鹧鸪。然后是3个法国母鸡，2个斑鸠，1只梨树上的鹧鸪。然后是4个鸣叫的鸟，3个法国母鸡，2个斑鸠，1只梨树上的鹧鸪。5个金戒指，4个鸣叫的鸟。所以……你知道会发生什么。它以最无聊的方式重复，而且总是唱得非常慢，这很烦人。
And I don't know why it survived hundred of years to still be around. And my only thought is "five golden rings." "Five golden rings" is the hook of the song. And you've sung the song, right? When you get to five golden rings, everybody breathes a sigh of relief. It's like, (SINGING) five golden rings. And you just feel like, yeah!
我不知道为什么它能存活几百年还存在着。我唯一的想法就是“5个金戒指”。“5个金戒指”是这首歌的钩子（洗脑点）。你们唱过这首歌，对吧？当唱到“5个金戒指”时，每个人都会松一口气。就像，（歌唱）5个金戒指。你只觉得，耶！
You know what I mean? It's like the drum solo. That's the hook of the song. And without five golden rings, this song would be nothing.
你懂我的意思吗？这就像鼓手独奏。那是这首歌的钩子。没有那5个金戒指，这首歌将一文不值。
Okay, so at this point-- this is me back in the studio talking-- at this point, if I could just describe the stage. Sitting on stools in a row, there are six improv comedians. And we got some of the best people around for this kind of thing. Seriously, we felt so lucky they agreed to be in the show. Aidy Bryant and Sasheer Zamata, they're both on Saturday Night Live . Scott Adsit, he was on 30 Rock , and before that, he was in Second City. So was Tammy Sagher. Chris Gethard and Mike Birbiglia, they've both been on our radio program before, Mike many, many times. They both have deep improv backgrounds.
好的，现在——这是我在录音室里说话——此时，如果我能描述一下舞台。六个即兴喜剧演员并排坐在凳子上。我们为这种表演找来了一些最棒的人选。说真的，我们感到非常幸运他们同意参加演出。艾迪·布莱恩特（Aidy Bryant）和萨希尔·扎马塔（Sasheer Zamata），她们都是《周六夜现场》的成员。斯科特·阿西特（Scott Adsit），他曾出演《我为喜剧狂》，在此之前，他是第二城剧团的成员。塔米·萨格（Tammy Sagher）也是如此。克里斯·格哈德（Chris Gethard）和迈克·比比利亚（Mike Birbiglia），他们之前都上过我们的广播节目，迈克来过很多很多次。他们都有深厚的即兴表演背景。
So six of them are sitting on the stage on these stools. And they listen to that first story that I told to kick things off. And Mike was the first one to stand up and speak.
所以他们六个人坐在舞台上的凳子上。他们听着我开场讲的第一个故事。迈克是第一个站起来发言的人。
Wow. Well, first of all I want to disagree with Ira about that song. I think in some sense, it's sort of the "15 Bottles of Beer on the Wall" of Christmas carols. It's anthemic. It's repetitive. I think where the disconnect happens is that it's just British things.
哇。首先，我想就那首歌和艾拉（Ira）持不同意见。我觉得某种意义上，它就像圣诞颂歌版的《墙上的15瓶啤酒》。它极具煽动性，重复性强。我觉得断层发生的原因是它全是英国玩意儿。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
[观众笑声]
What kind of American things would you put in there? Like a bald eagle? A bald eagle in a-- in a what, oak tree?
你会放些什么样的美国玩意儿进去？比如秃鹰？秃鹰在——在什么树上，橡树吗？
Yeah. Bald eagle in an oak tree. Yeah, we just got to de-British the whole thing. I think that's the problem.
对。橡树上的秃鹰。没错，我们得把这整首歌“去英国化”。我觉得那是关键问题所在。
Lady Haversquire.
海弗斯夸尔夫人（Lady Haversquire）。
Yes?
什么事？
We've been courting now for going on 10 months. And--
我们求爱已经快10个月了。而且——
Yes?
是吗？
--I've been playing in my mind with what to get you for Christmas.
——我一直在心里盘算圣诞节给你买什么。
Lord Mavermunch, I am sure that whatever you will bring me on Christmas will bring me much-- what?
马弗蒙奇勋爵（Lord Mavermunch），我相信无论你圣诞节带给我什么，都会带给我……什么？
May I give it you now?
我可以现在就给你吗？
Oh! Yes, but so soon before Christmas?
噢！可以，但距离圣诞节还有这么久？
I'm excited. I think I did well.
我很兴奋。我觉得我表现得很好。
All right.
好吧。
Here you are-- five golden rings.
给你——5个金戒指。
Oh. Oh my goodness.
噢。天哪。
But I've also brought you 23 birds.
但我还给你带了23只鸟。
Sorry?
抱歉？
23 individual birds and 50 human people.
23只独立的鸟，还有50个人类。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
[观众笑声]
Could you stay in a group, please?
你们能不能聚在一起？
[GROUP TALKING OVER EACH OTHER]
[人群嘈杂声]
Guys, guys, guys.
伙计们，伙计们。
We are the Christmas presents.
我们是圣诞礼物。
Do you like it?
你喜欢吗？
I-- I love it. Um, Lord Mavermunch, um, if we could just go back for a moment to the five golden rings.
我——我很喜欢。嗯，马弗蒙奇勋爵，嗯，如果我们能回到刚才的5个金戒指……
Ah, yes.
啊，是的。
Yes. Ah, so two questions. Question number one-- what is the difference between a gold ring and a golden ring? Because one seems to imply that it merely has the color, yet none of the value.
是的。啊，所以有两个问题。第一个问题——金戒指（gold ring）和镀金戒指（golden ring）有什么区别？因为一个似乎暗示它仅仅拥有颜色，却没有任何价值。
Well, you've caught me there. I'm afraid to say the pear tree cost rather more than I expected.
好吧，你问住我了。恐怕梨树的成本比我预期的要高。
Lord Mavermunch?
马弗蒙奇勋爵？
Lady Haversquire?
海弗斯夸尔夫人？
Do you remember when you first came courting?
你记得你刚开始追求我的时候吗？
Oh, yes. My memory is intact.
噢，当然。我的记忆力很完好。
Was it? Because I distinctly remember telling you I don't like a turtle dove. I find roses played out. And quite frankly, lords a leaping I've seen enough. And yet that's all you seem to have brought.
是吗？因为我清楚地记得告诉你我不喜欢斑鸠。我觉得玫瑰花太俗气了。说实话，跳跃的领主我已经看够了。然而你似乎只带了这些。
Oh, come on!
噢，拜托！
Oh, hey, come on!
噢，嘿，拜托！
We're so good! Watch this! Hut, hut, hut!
我们很棒！看着！嘿，嘿，嘿！
[GRUNTING]
[呻吟声]
I'm going so high!
我跳得好高！
Look, just--
看，只是——
Do you know what they call you in the county?
你知道郡里的人怎么称呼你吗？
I don't.
我不知道。
They call you Quantity over Quality.
他们叫你“追求数量不顾质量”。
Scene.
场景结束。
[AUDIENCE CHEERING]
[观众欢呼]
I wonder if you guys actually have memories-- did any of you have to go caroling? Or did you sing in--
我好奇你们有没有真实的记忆——你们中有人必须去唱圣歌吗？或者你们在……唱过吗？
I am also super Jewish. I'm Israeli Jewish. So the level of--
我也是超级犹太人。我是以色列裔犹太人。所以那种……程度……
Oh, you totally out-Jew me.
噢，你完全比我更像犹太人。
Yeah. But I was in the Chicago Children's Choir. And it was a little kids choir. And the big thing that you do at Christmas is sing Christmas carols. So two things that I remember very well from Christmas choir was one was I got a solo that I got to do. Yeah. And I screwed up, and that was horrifying.
对。但我曾在芝加哥儿童合唱团。那是一个小孩子合唱团。在圣诞节你做的大事就是唱圣诞颂歌。关于圣诞合唱团，有两件事我记忆犹新，一是我有一次获得了独唱机会。是的。但我搞砸了，那真是太可怕了。
The other thing that just occurred to me now is-- so it was on the South Side of Chicago. So it was pretty racially diverse, meaning I usually was the minority, not just as a Jew but as a white person, in choir. And so we also did a lot of gospels, which is where I discovered that I can't clap. And it became something that I would practice at home.
另一件我现在突然想起的事是——那是在芝加哥南区。所以种族背景相当多样，意味着我通常是少数派，不仅作为犹太人，而且作为合唱团里的白人。所以我们也会唱很多福音歌曲，在那我发现我根本不会拍手。这成了我回家练习的事情。
Could I just have clarification, just as a fact-checking matter? You would practice clapping.
我能确认一下吗，作为事实核查？你回家练习拍手？
Yeah.
对。
To what? Like what would be the sound--
对着什么？声音大概是——
Just radio. I would just turn on the radio, and I'd be like, [CLAPPING] I would just, like, try to clap on the beat. Because if you don't know how to clap and you're in a choir clapping, it's terrifying.
就是收音机。我打开收音机，然后我会像这样，[拍手声]，我会尝试跟着节拍拍手。因为如果你不会拍手，又在合唱团里，那真的很可怕。
Bernice, I was watching you sing in the chorus.
伯尼斯（Bernice），我刚才看着你在合唱团唱歌。
Oh, wow. You saw me? Wow.
噢，哇。你看到我了？哇。
I see everything. I'm Jesus.
我看到一切。我是耶稣。
Oh, wow-- this is-- this is so cool for me. This is huge.
噢，哇——这——这对我来说太酷了。这太重要了。
Oh, listen, it's an honor to meet you.
噢，听着，见到你真是荣幸。
Oh, my god. Thank you. Thank you, Jesus.
噢，天哪。谢谢。谢谢你，耶稣。
You know I hear that all day? But it still means a lot when you say it.
你知道我整天都能听到这些吗？但当你这么说时，意义依然重大。
Aw, Jesus, you're so nice.
噢，耶稣，你真好。
I got to tell you. You really should not be singing.
我得告诉你。你真的不应该唱歌。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
[观众笑声]
[SINGING OFF-KEY] What do you mean? What do you mean by what you're saying?
[跑调歌唱] 什么意思？你刚才说的话是什么意思？
Well, I think--
嗯，我想——
What do you mean?
什么意思？
Bernice, I--
伯尼斯，我——
Jesus, don't say that to me!
耶稣，别那样对我说话！
Bernice, I think you're answering your own question there.
伯尼斯，我觉得你自己在那回答了自己的问题。
You know, I'm the Holy Spirit. And I just wanted to chime in. I think Bernice has a really nice voice. I--
你知道，我是圣灵。我只是想插一句。我觉得伯尼斯的声音真的很不错。我——
Dave, I told you not to come.
戴夫，我告诉过你别来。
All right.
好吧。
Well, maybe it's because I'm singing, like, gorgeous God songs. Maybe you want more of like a pop hit or something?
嗯，也许是因为我唱的是那些华丽的赞美诗。也许你想要更多流行歌曲之类的？
No, what I'm saying is that you are singing from your heart, but your heart is not good enough. It really puts other people off, and it's pushing people away from me. I need people. I need more people.
不，我的意思是，你是用真心在唱，但你的真心还不够好。它确实让别人感到反感，并且在把我的人往外推。我需要人。我需要更多人。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
[观众笑声]
We cut to a television executive's office. I got to say, we got this show, and the judges, they're too soft. And I think you're the exact kind of hard edge we need, Jesus.
我们切换到电视台高管办公室。我得说，我们要办这个节目，但评委们太软弱了。我觉得你正是我们需要的那种硬派人物，耶稣。
Well, I appreciate the compliment. But I would be happy to do the job, but let me also warn you that when I bring judgment, that's the end of the world.
好吧，我感谢你的恭维。我很乐意做这份工作，但我也得警告你，当我降下审判时，那就是世界末日了。
Listen, that's the kind of ratings bonanza I've been looking for, OK?
听着，那正是我一直在寻找的收视神话，明白吗？
I'm in.
我加入。
CeeLo, Aguilera, they softball it, Adam Levine. They all feel bad. Nobody gives an honest opinion. I need somebody who's going to be harsh. I need somebody who's going to be brutal, who's going to say, "This is exactly how I see it."
希洛（CeeLo）、阿奎莱拉（Aguilera）、亚当·列维（Adam Levine），他们都太温和了。他们都觉得不好意思。没人给出真诚的意见。我需要一个会说狠话的人。我需要一个会冷酷无情的人，一个会说：“这就是我眼中的真相”的人。
Don't talk to me about Adam Levine, man.
别跟我提亚当·列维，伙计。
What do I gotta do to get you on my network? I know money means nothing to you. You're omnipotent. You know everything. You have access to everything. What do I gotta do to get you on my airwaves?
我要怎么做才能让你加入我的频道？我知道钱对你毫无意义。你是万能的。你知道一切。你拥有通往一切的门路。我要怎么做才能让你在我的电波里出现？
I want you to live your life as I would live mine.
我希望你按照我生活的方式去生活。
[GROAN]
[呻吟声]
Scene!
场景结束！
My Jewish brothers, welcome. I call this meeting.
我的犹太兄弟们，欢迎。我召集这次会议。
You called this minion.
你召集了这个……（单词误用）。
Thank you for--
谢谢你——
There's 10 of us. I got to say there's 10 of us.
我们有10个人。我得说我们有10个人。
Thank you for the correction, Jacob. I call this minion to discuss our grievances with Christmas as a holiday. I know it's not our holiday. But I know that I have some concerns.
谢谢你的纠正，雅各布。我召集这次会议是为了讨论我们对圣诞节作为假期的不满。我知道这不是我们的节日。但我知道我有一些担忧。
Brother Abraham, I think you should adjust your level of Jew-y. It's a little high.
亚伯拉罕兄弟，我觉得你应该调整一下你的“犹太感”。有点太浓了。
Oh! Here it is. It's on my anklet here. There we are.
噢！在这里。就在我的脚踝饰带上。找到了。
Oh, well--
噢，好吧——
Well, I don't like it!
嗯，我不喜欢它！
Okay, this is Ira in the studio. I'm just going to stop the tape for a second just to make perfectly clear what's happening on stage right now. OK, so the first comedian in the scene, Mike Birbiglia, he had some trouble with his Jewish accent, as you heard, and he was teased about it. And then another comedian, Aidy Bryant, entered the scene. And she has so much trouble coming up with a Jewish accent that at some point, that just becomes what the scene is about, is her discomfort at this awful accent, and the other performers kind of egging her on and also ribbing her about it very affectionately. OK, back to the scene.
好的，这是在录音室的艾拉。我暂停录音片刻，明确一下现在舞台上发生了什么。好的，第一个即兴表演者迈克·比比利亚，正如你们听到的，他在尝试犹太口音时遇到了一些困难，并被取笑了。然后另一个演员艾迪·布莱恩特加入了场景。她对于模仿犹太口音极其困难，以至于到最后，这直接变成了场景的核心——关于她对这种糟糕口音的不适，以及其他演员以一种极其亲昵的方式在戏弄和怂恿她。好了，回到场景。
Well--
嗯——
Well, I don't like it! I don't like the holiday one bit.
嗯，我不喜欢它！我不喜欢这个节日一点点。
I want to welcome our brother from the Italian branch of Judaism.
我想欢迎我们来自意大利犹太教分支的兄弟。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
[观众笑声]
Hey, what's the big deal?
嘿，出什么大事了？
Thank you, Antonio, for bringing the 24 pizzas. We hope everything's going well at the temple out in Bay Ridge.
谢谢你，安东尼奥（Antonio），带了24个披萨。我们希望湾岭（Bay Ridge）的会堂一切顺利。
It truly is. Please continue. I'll stay quiet, I promise, for the rest of the meeting.
确实很好。请继续。我保持安静，我保证，会议剩下的时间里。
Antonio, you guys have been getting sweat everywhere.
安东尼奥，你们带得满地都是汗。
Eh, my favorite thing about being Jewish is, of course, the sweet lasagna! And I want everyone to know that I'm trying my absolute hardest. I feel we must move on.
嘿，我最喜欢犹太身份的就是，当然，甜蜜的千层面！我希望每个人都知道我已经在极尽全力了。我觉得我们必须继续。
Scene.
场景结束。
[AUDIENCE CHEERING]
[观众欢呼]
I'm sorry. I'm sorry to all the cultures everywhere around the world.
我很抱歉。我向世界各地所有的文化道歉。
Fellas, fellas, fellas, get in here. Fellas, I'm working on--
伙计们，伙计们，过来。伙计们，我正在努力——
Yeah, yeah, yeah, what's up? Yeah.
对，对，对，怎么了？
I wanted to get the group back together for a Christmas song. And I was just thinking this one would be just "Five Golden Rings."
我想把大家重新组织起来唱一首圣诞歌。我刚才在想，这首歌就只唱“5个金戒指”。
Whoa.
哇。
Wow, OK.
哇，好的。
Jettison the other verses.
抛弃其他段落。
Mm-hm.
嗯哼。
We hit five golden rings hard, right? We circle back. You could do some scatting.
我们要有力地唱好5个金戒指，对吧？我们循环回来。你可以加点即兴吟唱（Scatting）。
Oh, my god. Well, I'm in! If you're going to finally let me do it, then doopity dop dop, yeah!
噢，天哪。好吧，我加入！如果你终于要让我做了，那就嘟比嘟吧，耶！
I just think we all need to accept the truth, which is that nobody likes the other verses.
我只是认为我们都需要接受真相，那就是没人喜欢其他段落。
I don't no, Jord. I feel like a lot of people are going to miss, like, calling birds.
我不觉得，乔德（Jord）。我觉得很多人会怀念像鸣叫的鸟之类的段落。
Yeah, or at least the nine ladies dancing. [SCATTING]
对，或者至少是那9个跳舞的女士。[即兴吟唱]
Scene.
场景结束。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Dad?
爸爸？
Yeah.
嗯。
I want to feed the geese.
我想喂鹅。
OK, we can do that. I just want to-- I just want to make sure you know they're an extremely vicious animal.
好的，我们可以那样做。我只是想——我只是想确保你知道它们是非常凶猛的动物。
[HONKING  LIKE A GOOSE]
[发出鹅叫声]
Dad, I've seen geese before. They're, like, really cute, and--
爸爸，我以前见过鹅。它们看起来，很可爱，而且——
OK. You know I'm a big believer in letting you learn your lessons.
好的。你知道我是那种让你从实践中学习的忠实信徒。
You always say that before, like, something really bad happens.
你每次在发生什么坏事之前都这么说。
I mean, I just tried to warn you. They can be a really aggressive animal.
我是说，我只是想警告你。它们可能是非常有攻击性的动物。
OK.
好的。
Sure, yeah.
确定，好吧。
Give me the bread.
把面包给我。
Yeah.
好的。
OK.
Go for broke, just remember what I told you.
放手去干，记住我告诉你的。
All right, come here, little goosey.
好吧，过来，小鹅鹅。
[GOOSE NOISES]
[鹅叫声]
Oh! [LAUGHS] Okay.
噢！[笑声] 好的。
Whoa, you are really beautiful.
哇，你真的太美了。
Oh, my gosh.
噢，天哪。
I'm sorry. I don't usually say that. But you are really gorgeous.
对不起。我通常不说这种话。但你真的太迷人了。
Thanks.
谢谢。
I mean, you're the kind of person that a goose would give up his whole life for. I mean, I could take you places. I'm going way too fast. I'm sorry. But you-- you're turning me around. [HONK] [GOOSE NOISES]
我是说，你是那种鹅会为之付出生命的。我是说，我可以带你去各地。我太快了。对不起。但你——你改变了我。[鹅叫声]
Did you hear that?
你听到了吗？
Yeah, like I told you-- super aggressive.
对，就像我告诉你的——超级有攻击性。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
[观众笑声]
Scene!
场景结束！
Did you guys have this as a kid, where the joy of Christmas, when I look back on it, I think has a lot to do with no school.
你们小时候有这种感觉吗，当我回顾圣诞节的快乐时，我觉得这和没上学有很大关系。
Oh, yes.
噢，是的。
Just this idea of "Wait, there's a week where there's no school?"
那种“等等，居然有一个星期不用上学？”的想法。
It's so different when you don't celebrate Christmas. Because for you, it's two weeks where you don't see your friends, because they are all going somewhere cool and having fun.
当你不过圣诞节时感觉完全不同。因为对你来说，那是两个星期看不到朋友，因为他们都去很酷的地方玩了。
But Jews also get the school break, too, right? It's not like you still have to go to school.
但犹太孩子也有寒假，对吧？也不是说你非得去上学。
But we love school!
但我们爱上学！
Children, gather around. We have a class-wide announcement.
孩子们，聚集过来。我们要宣布一个全班通告。
All right.
好吧。
The Jews--
犹太人——
This is never good.
这准没好事。
Scene!
场景结束！
[AUDIENCE CHEERING]
[观众欢呼]
I was just going to tell a quick story.
我原本打算讲个短故事。
I'm going to listen.
我会听的。
Great. Well, I feel like we keep talking about, like, especially people who were always experiencing a Jewish Christmas experience. But I was the exact opposite, where until I was 13 years old, I did not know Jewish people existed maybe. And I loved Christmas so much that I would get up at 3:00 in the morning to try and look at my presents.
太棒了。嗯，我觉得我们一直在谈论，特别是那些一直有犹太圣诞经历的人。但我刚好相反，我在13岁之前，甚至可能不知道犹太人的存在。我太喜欢圣诞节了，以至于我会在凌晨3点起床去看我的礼物。
And I just always felt like such simple things would give me such overwhelming joy that I wish I could have that now. Like, one Christmas morning I was in my little Christmas gown, and I crept down, and there was a giant stuffed animal Saint Bernard, which is not like a bike that you can ride or something that you can do. It's just going to sit there, and you're going to look at it and love it. And as soon as I saw it, I was so happy I could not believe my eyes. I fell to my knees and I [BLEEP] my pants.
我总是觉得简单的东西就能带给我如此巨大的快乐，真希望现在还能有那种感觉。比如，某个圣诞早晨，我穿着我的小圣诞睡袍，悄悄走下楼，那里有一个巨大的填充玩具圣伯纳犬，它不像自行车那样可以骑，或者像其他东西那样可以玩。它只是坐在那里，你只会看着它并爱上它。一看到它，我就开心得不敢相信自己的眼睛。我跪倒在地，然后[哔]了我的裤子。
I just-- like upon the sight of this Saint Bernard, I just was like, thank you! And I fell to my knees and just blasted right into my pants. So I had to creep into my parents' room and say, like, "Good morning, Mom. Merry Christmas. I've soiled myself, and I need your help."
我只是——看到那个圣伯纳犬的瞬间，我就想，谢谢你！我跪下，然后直接拉在裤子里了。所以我不得不偷偷潜进父母的房间说，“早安，妈妈。圣诞快乐。我把裤子弄脏了，我需要你的帮助。”
Can I ask the other improv stars on stage, like, did you have moments like that, of such incredible joy at Christmas? Not that would take your body to that length, but do you know what I mean? Like moments of just pure, pure joy in that way that I think we rarely have as adults. Do you have--
我能问问舞台上其他的即兴巨星吗，你们小时候有过那样的时刻吗，在圣诞节感受到难以置信的快乐？不是说会让你身体失控的那种，但你明白我的意思吗？就是那种纯粹的，纯粹的快乐，我想我们成年后很少有那种体验。你们有——
When I was a kid, my sister and I would get up really early and stand at the top of the stairs, because we knew we weren't allowed to go downstairs. And my dad had this tradition. We would have to wait for him to-- we would just shake with anticipation at the top of the stairs, and wait and wait, and bother them, my parents, to get out of bed. And we'd pull them out of bed. And they would take their sweet time putting on their clothes and getting their shaving, just to torture us, because they knew we were at the top of the stairs.
当我还是个孩子，我和我姐姐会起得很早，站在楼梯顶端，因为我们知道不能下楼。但我爸爸有个传统。我们要等他——我们在楼梯顶端激动得发抖，一直等啊等，去骚扰他们，我的父母，让他们起床。我们会把他们从床上拽起来。而他们会磨磨蹭蹭地穿衣服、刮胡子，纯粹是为了折磨我们，因为他们知道我们在楼梯顶端。
And my dad would go downstairs first and say, "Let's see if Santa came." Like, he'd look around the hallway and say, "I don't see any evidence that he's been here." And then he'd walk into the dining room, and he would disappear. And we'd hear him go, "Well, mm, no, nothing in here."
爸爸会先下楼说，“看看圣诞老人来了没。”他会环顾四周说，“我没看到他来过的迹象。”然后他会走进餐厅，他就消失了。我们听到他说，“嗯，没，这儿什么都没有。”
And we're up there, going like, "It's the dining room. There's nothing in the dining room!" Goes into this kind of side little sitting room and same thing. He disappears. He does the same shtick of "No, nothing in here." And then he'd say-- inevitably, he'd say, "I don't know if he came."
我们在楼上喊，“那是餐厅。餐厅里本来就不会有！”他走进旁边的小休息室，也是同样的事。他消失了。他重复同样的把戏：“没，这儿什么都没有。”然后他会说——不可避免地，他说，“不知道他有没有来。”
The first couple years, we were really nervous that maybe Santa did not come. But then after three or four years of this, we were like, "Of course he came. Everything's in the-- go to the family room! Go to the family-- were the tree is, where the fireplace is. Santa's not going to come down and then cart everything into the dining room."
前几年，我们真的很紧张，怕圣诞老人没来。但三四年后，我们想，“他当然来了。东西都在——去家庭厅（Family Room）！去家庭厅——那是树所在地，壁炉所在地。圣诞老人不会下楼然后把所有东西搬进餐厅的。”
Dad, you idiot! Go to the family room!
爸爸，你这个白痴！去家庭厅！
Family room! Family room! Go to the-- [GROAN]
家庭厅！家庭厅！去——[呻吟]
Nothing in here.
这儿什么都没有。
Oh, my god! Dad, I will kill you! Please let us down the stairs!
噢，天哪！爸爸，我要杀了你！请让我们下楼梯！
Maybe I'll go look up in the attic.
也许我会去阁楼看看。
What's wrong with you? What's wrong with you? It's not going to be in the attic.
你有什么毛病？你有什么毛病？东西又不会在阁楼。
Oh, guys. Your dad's having fun. Come on.
噢，孩子们。你们爸爸在找乐子。好了。
Point your stupid freshly-shaven face towards the family room.
把那张蠢蠢的刚刮过胡子的脸朝向家庭厅吧。
I want to talk to you guys about your dad.
我想和你们聊聊你们爸爸。
OK.
好的。
He has Alzheimer's.
他有阿尔茨海默症。
What?
什么？
He doesn't know where the presents are.
他不知道礼物在哪。
That is true. We've been saying he was having fun, but holy hell.
那是真的。我们一直以为他在开玩笑，但我的天啊。
Scene!
场景结束！
[AUDIENCE CHEERING]
[观众欢呼]
Ho, ho, ho, come in here, elves.
呵呵呵，进来，精灵们。
OK, Mr. Santy Claus.
好的，圣诞老人。
Ho, ho, ho! Merry Christmas.
呵呵呵！圣诞快乐。
Thank you again.
再次谢谢你。
I know you want to tell you something I've never told you about Christmas.
我知道你们想告诉我关于圣诞节我从未告诉过你们的事。
Santa, we've been working for you for 472 years. You're going to have to dig deep in that bag.
圣诞老人，我们为你工作了472年了。你得在那袋子里深挖一下。
Well, I've told you that it's a magical time of year.
嗯，我告诉过你们这是一年中神奇的时刻。
Uh-huh, uh-huh.
嗯哼，嗯哼。
I've told you we give presents to millions of children in the world.
我告诉过你们我们给世界上数百万的孩子送礼物。
Mm-hm.
嗯哼。
We know. We make all that stuff.
我们知道。那些东西都是我们做的。
Yeah, we do that.
对，我们做了那些。
But I haven't told you Rudolph has cancer. The red nose is--
但我没告诉你们鲁道夫得癌症了。红鼻子是——
Why didn't we get him treated? He's had that red nose for so long.
为什么我们没给他治疗？他的红鼻子已经很久了。
For years, we just thought it was adorable.
多年来，我们一直以为那是可爱的。
I feel so bad we used to laugh and call him names.
我真愧疚，我们以前总是嘲笑他并给他起外号。
Scene!
场景结束！
I have a question. I wonder what you guys think of this. And I think this makes me sound like a bad person. Do you feel like Christmas loses a lot of the joy when you hit an age where you have to start buying presents for other people?
我有个问题。我想知道你们是怎么想的。我觉得这让我听起来像个坏人。你们觉得当你们到了不得不开始给别人买礼物的年纪，圣诞节的乐趣是否会减少很多？
I have not hit that age.
我还没到那个年纪。
Really?
真的吗？
1,000% yes.
1000%同意。
I feel like it takes-- it's like a fun magic thing, and then when you actually have to give back to other people, it becomes such a drag. Such a drag.
我觉得它带走了——它原本是件好玩的神奇事，然后当你真的不得不回报别人时，它就变成了一种负担。真的是负担。
Your parents didn't make you give presents to your siblings?
你父母没让你给兄弟姐妹送礼物？
To my sibling? Yeah, I had one brother. Our elementary school rent-- did you guys have this? Our elementary school had a thing that was just bad presents. It's like, you'd go into the gym and be like, oh, you can buy your dad a little screwdriver set, or you can buy your mom a plastic ring. It was all the same stuff. So every year, my brother was just an interchangeable-- like, "I got you the neon flyswatter." "Great, I got you the slap bracelet." You know? And our mom would give us the money anyway.
给兄弟姐妹？有，我有一个兄弟。我们小学卖——你们有过吗？我们小学有个活动就是专门卖烂礼物。就像，你进体育馆，噢，你可以给爸爸买个小螺丝刀套装，或者给妈妈买个塑料戒指。全是一样的货。所以每年，我兄弟和我就是互换——“我给了你这个霓虹苍蝇拍。”“太棒了，我给了你这个啪啪圈。”你知道吗？反正妈妈会给我们钱。
This might sound cynical. My wife and I, we don't give each other Christmas presents, because neither of us believe in holidays.
这听起来可能很愤世嫉俗。我和我妻子，我们不给彼此送圣诞礼物，因为我们都不信这些节日。
You don't believe in them?
你们不信它们？
Well, they're out there.
嗯，它们就在那儿。
Like, they exist.
就像，它们存在。
Every 4th of July, do you think a war is breaking out?
每逢7月4日，你觉得战争爆发了吗？
No, to Chris's point, neither of us like the pressure of having to get a gift. And we just don't like them. So we're just like, "No, we don't want that in our relationship."
不，针对克里斯的观点，我们都不喜欢必须送礼物的压力。而且我们都不喜欢礼物。所以我们就像，“不，我们不希望这存在于我们的关系里。”
Well, I'm the opposite. When I grew up, I remember the first presents I bought. And it's still essentially true of me now, is that I'm really excited for people to open the present I found or made for them. And watching them open other people's presents makes me angry. And I just am waiting for them to get to my present.
嗯，我正好相反。我长大时，记得我买的第一份礼物。这直到现在对我来说依然基本适用，就是我真的很兴奋看到人们打开我为他们找到或制作的礼物。看到他们打开别人的礼物反而让我生气。我只是在等他们轮到拆我的礼物。
I'm going to walk you back on that one. Are you making a lot of presents?
我要收回刚才的话。你做了很多礼物？
Found or made?
找到或制作的？
Same thing.
一回事。
What is unusual about that?
那有什么不寻常的吗？
You're a really good person.
你真是个好人。
Mom, mom.
妈妈，妈妈。
Oh, sweetie.
噢，宝贝。
I got this for you.
这是给你的。
Oh, sweetie.
噢，宝贝。
It's a paper puppet.
这是一个纸木偶。
Oh. Oh, honey.
噢。噢，亲爱的。
It's a paper puppet.
这是一个纸木偶。
Honey.
亲爱的。
What did you get me?
你送我什么了？
You know what? Greg, now is not a good time.
你知道吗？格雷格，现在不是好时候。
Oh, OK.
噢，好的。
Sorry. Sweet-- Mom's friend, Greg, he might want a paper puppet to play with, too.
抱歉。亲爱的——妈妈的朋友格雷格，他也可能想玩玩纸木偶。
Yeah. Yeah, Greg might want a paper puppet.
对。对，格雷格可能也想要个纸木偶。
I only made one paper puppet.
我只做了一个纸木偶。
Well, you know what? That's great, honey, because Greg and Mommy are going to share, because sharing is caring.
嗯，你知道吗？那太棒了，亲爱的，因为格雷格和妈咪要分享，因为分享就是关怀。
Yeah. (SINGING) Sharing is caring.
对。（歌唱）分享就是关怀。
OK.
好的。
I want you to share the paper puppet.
我希望你分享那个纸木偶。
Oh, that's awesome. Yeah, thank you for that. That's nice.
噢，那太棒了。对，谢谢你。真好。
Greg, you please put on a robe?
格雷格，请你穿上长袍好吗？
Sure, I guess so.
好的，我想可以吧。
OK, sweetie, now remember, we said when Greg's over, we're going to knock on the door and we're not going to come in at 3:00. I love my paper puppet. I love my paper puppet, but it's time to go back to bed, OK, sweetie?
好的，亲爱的，现在记得，我们说过格雷格来的时候，我们会敲门，不会在3点钟闯进来。我爱我的纸木偶。我爱我的纸木偶，但该回床上睡觉了，好吗，亲爱的？
Can I get in bed with you guys?
我能去你们床上吗？
Not a good time, baby. Not a good time.
现在不是时候，宝贝。现在不是时候。
And I want to be honest.
而且我想诚实点。
No, maybe not. Not a good time.
不，也许不行。现在不是时候。
Scene!
场景结束！
Wait, so probably not use able, but for my own sake, there's two things that we went past that I want to hear. And one is what Greg was going to say when he said, "Can I be honest with you?"
等等，这可能用不上，但为了我自己的好奇心，有两件事我们跳过了，我想听听。一是格雷格说“我能跟你坦白吗”时原本想说什么。
Greg was going to say, "I'm going to be honest. I didn't get you anything. But your present will be a father figure, if you play your cards right."
格雷格原本想说：“我要坦白。我什么都没给你买。但如果你表现得好，你的礼物将是一位父亲形象。”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
[观众笑声]
You know what? There was no, like, religious factor in my Christmas experience. But it was all about like creating your own magic, I feel like. Like, we had this family tradition where Christmas Eve, everyone had to do one trick, which could be of any sort. And then if you did your trick, you got to open one present before you went to bed.
你知道吗？我的圣诞经历里没什么宗教因素。但我感觉这全关于创造你自己的魔法。就像，我们家有个传统，平安夜每个人必须表演一个把戏，任何类型的都可以。然后如果你表演了把戏，你可以在上床前拆一份礼物。
And now you're a professional performer.
现在你成了专业演员。
I know. But you know what? Like, all the tricks-- I mean, it was all kinds of things. Like I remember one year, my aunt and uncle timed like a nostril flashlight dance to dueling banjos. And like--
我知道。但你知道吗？那些把戏——我是说，各种各样的东西。我记得有一年，我的姑姑和姨夫配合着《决斗班卓琴》做了一个鼻孔手电筒舞蹈。就像——
What?
什么？
Welcome to the Bryant Family Talent Show. Does anyone want to start?
欢迎来到布莱恩特家庭才艺秀。有人想开始吗？
I think, Jeff, we've got a real great lineup.
我觉得，杰夫，我们有非常棒的阵容。
Oh, we got a great lineup.
噢，我们有很棒的阵容。
We're really excited.
我们真的很兴奋。
Great. Big, big, big, big lineup this year.
很棒。阵容很大很大，今年。
But I have to say I've been hearing whisperings from Samantha that she's got a real great talent coming up.
但我得说我听到萨曼莎（Samantha）在窃窃私语说她有个很棒的才艺要登场。
It's not ready!
还没准备好！
Oh!
噢！
It's not ready. It's not ready.
还没准备好。还没准备好。
OK, sweetie. OK.
好的，亲爱的。好的。
Stall, stall!
拖延，拖延！
OK, sweetie. It's OK. It's OK, sweetie.
好的，亲爱的。没关系。没关系，亲爱的。
All right, we'll just do some banter. We'll do some banter.
好的，我们做点闲聊。做点闲聊。
Or we could ask Michael if he's ready.
或者我们可以问问迈克尔（Michael）他准备好了没。
Yeah, I'm ready. I've been ready for this all year. I've been waiting for this opportunity all year.
对，我准备好了。我整年都在等待这个机会。
Michael, I'm going to remind you of the ages of everybody in the family.
迈克尔，我要提醒你家里每个人的年龄。
OK. OK.
好的。好的。
All right, so--
好的，所以——
Yeah, I'll remind you of my age. I'm 16, and I'm finally seeing the world for what it is, man. I'm finally seeing the world what it is. I'm 16, man.
对，我会提醒你我的年龄。我16岁了，我终于看清了这个世界，伙计。我终于看清了世界是什么样。我16岁了，伙计。
OK, Michael.
好的，迈克尔。
Michael, Michael.
迈克尔，迈克尔。
Michael, calm down.
迈克尔，冷静点。
Michael.
迈克尔。
Yeah.
对。
Calm down.
冷静点。
Michael.
迈克尔。
OK.
好的。
Calm down. Calm down.
冷静点。冷静点。
Michael, relax.
迈克尔，放松。
I'm calm. Who's-- I'm calm. I'm calm!
我很冷静。谁——我很冷静。我很冷静！
Uncurl your fists.
松开你的拳头。
Who's yelling?
谁在叫？
Uncurl your fists.
松开你的拳头。
That's just how my hands are comfy.
我的手舒服就这样。
Hey.
嘿。
This is how my hands are comfortable.
我的手舒服就是这样。
Michael?
迈克尔？
What?
什么？
Are those brass knuckles?
那是指虎吗？
No, not if you don't hit anybody with them.
不，如果你不打人就不是。
Michael, put those away.
迈克尔，把它收起来。
They're just interconnected rings.
它们只是互锁的环。
We--
我们——
Can I have them? Can I have them?
能给我吗？能给我吗？
Yeah, take them. Do whatever you want with them.
对，拿去。随便你怎么处置。
Cool. (SINGING) Five golden rings.
酷。（歌唱）5个金戒指。
Give them back. Give them back. Anything but that. Anything but that.
还给我。还给我。除了那个都可以。除了那个都可以。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
[观众笑声]
I think one of the things that's really evocative about Christmas and childhood is actually fire. Like, we used to make fires.
我觉得圣诞节和童年最能引起共鸣的事情其实是火。就像，我们以前生火。
What?
什么？
In the fireplace, where one makes fire.
在壁炉里，人们生火的地方。
You said "we" like every-- like it's a common experience.
你说的“我们”好像每个人——好像这是一种普遍的体验。
Like collectively we all associate Christmas with fire.
好像集体地，我们都把圣诞节和火联系在一起。
I agree with Mike, where we always had like a big, beautiful fireplace where we would kind of gather around. But my parents remodeled their house when I was probably 11 a little bit. And they redid the fireplace, and it was like all these river rocks. Gorgeous, I know.
我同意迈克的看法，我们一直有个巨大、漂亮的壁炉，我们可以聚在那里。但我父母在我11岁左右时重新装修了房子。他们重做了壁炉，全是河卵石。很华丽，我知道。
But they were, like, fake, you know? I mean, you couldn't tell that if you went, except for there's still to this day one at the very top that's deflated. It's like this deflated river rock. And so in all our Christmas pictures, it's all of us seated in front of the fireplace, and hanging above us is this weird, indented, sort of like light gray river rock.
但它们是，假货，你知道吗？我是说，除非你走过去看，否则你分辨不出来，除了至今最上方还有一块是瘪的。就像这块瘪掉的河卵石。所以在我们所有的圣诞照片里，我们全家人坐在壁炉前，在我们上方悬挂着这块奇怪的、凹陷的、浅灰色的河卵石。
Um, what's a river rock?
嗯，什么是河卵石？
Oh, I'm sorry. I was born and raised in the desert. So we're always searching for rivers. No, it's just-- they're like rounded rocks.
噢，抱歉。我在沙漠长大。所以我们总是寻找河流。不，它只是——它们是像圆形的石头。
So they couldn't get real ones? They had to get fake ones?
所以他们弄不到真的？非要弄假的？
Whoa, burn. Taking my family to task.
哇，好毒的舌头。在指责我的家人。
Also, is it full of air? Like, why is it deflated?
还有，里面是充满空气的吗？为什么它是瘪的？
Look, I didn't build it. I just-- I frickin' lived it.
看，不是我建的。我只是——我该死地经历了它。
Aidy, can you come here for a sec, sweetie?
艾迪，能过来一下吗，亲爱的？
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Loved hearing you on the radio.
很高兴在广播里听到你。
OK.
好的。
I have to say, your dad and I got real sad though with what story you had to tell.
但我得说，你爸爸和我听了你的故事之后真的很伤心。
Um, I guess I-- I don't know. They chose that one. I did a ton of other nice stories.
嗯，我想我——我不知道。他们选了那一个。我讲了很多其他温馨的故事。
Did you talk about what happened when we gave you a four-foot St. Bernard stuffed toy?
你有没有提我们给你送了一个四英尺高的圣伯纳毛绒玩具时发生了什么？
I'm going to stop this scene.
我要停下这个场景。
Really, why? Why, you don't want to hear our opinions on how your hip, tight-pants friends don't like our rocks? Your hip friends with the tight pants?
真的，为什么？怎么，不想听我们评价你的那些穿紧身裤的朋友为什么不喜欢我们的石头吗？你那些穿着紧身裤的朋友们？
They act like they don't know what a rock is.
他们装得好像不知道什么是石头。
They act they like they don't know what a rock is. Oh, because you say "river," you don't know it's just a rock.
他们装得好像不知道什么是石头。噢，就因为你说了“河”，你就不知道那只是石头。
Hey, I heard your daughter on the radio.
嘿，我在广播里听到你女儿的声音了。
Yeah.
对。
We're avid-- Teresa and I are avid listeners to the public radio station here in Arizona. And it was very disappointing to hear that your family is an embarrassing family.
对，特蕾莎（Teresa）和我是这里公共广播电台的忠实听众。听到你的家庭是个让人尴尬的家庭，真的很令人失望。
Scene!
场景结束！
I will say the thing that was particularly special about Christmas-- because when I try to analyze what it is that made me experience this absolute euphoria in these two days is that my dad was there. My dad's a doctor, you know, which is wonderful. You know, he's a great doctor.
我要说圣诞节特别特别的地方——因为当我尝试分析是什么让我在这两天体验到这种绝对的欣快时，是因为我爸爸在那儿。我爸爸是医生，你知道，这很棒。你知道，他是个伟大的医生。
But there would be no two days in the year for sure when I would know that he would be around for those two days. And it was like-- there was something where there was this joy of the full family that I'll never forget.
但一年中绝对没有两天我会确定他会在家。这就像——那种全家团聚的快乐，我永生难忘。
Kids, kids, line up. Daddy's going to be here today. He's going to be here today.
孩子们，孩子们，排好队。爸爸今天会在这里。他今天会在这里。
Promise? You promise? There's nothing that could stop that, right?
承诺？你保证？没什么能阻止这一点，对吧？
No, he's coming. Today is the day. He wrote us. He told us. He phoned. Everything's all set.
没，他会来。今天就是那一天。他写信给我们。他告诉我们了。他打电话了。一切都准备好了。
Oh, man. I'm going to get love from him. I'm going to get advice from him. I'm going to get a spanking from them, because I've been bad.
噢，伙计。我要从他那儿得到爱。我要从他那儿得到建议。我要从他们那儿得到惩罚，因为我一直很淘气。
I have so many questions to ask him that will shape how I view men.
我有太多问题要问他，这些将塑造我看待男人的方式。
I'm just going to quietly observe him and then mimic him subtly forever.
我会静静地观察他，然后永远地模仿他。
I'm so excited!
我太兴奋了！
I can't wait!
我等不及了！
Oh, here he comes.
噢，他来了。
Oh, Dad!
噢，爸爸！
Dad!
爸爸！
Kids. Tammy, Aidy, what's your name? Sasheer? Something with an S.
孩子们。塔米，艾迪，你叫什么名字？萨希尔？以S开头的名字。
It's Samantha. I'm your wife.
是萨曼莎。我是你妻子。
Dad, Dad, look at my awards!
爸爸，爸爸，看我的奖状！
Very nice.
非常好。
Dad, spank me! I stole two years ago!
爸爸，打我屁股！我两年前偷东西了！
I just don't see why we have to go crazy like this. I don't see why we all have to go so crazy.
我只是不明白我们为什么要像这样疯狂。我不明白为什么我们大家都得变得这么疯狂。
Because we miss you!
因为我们想你！
You're never around!
你从不在家！
Dad, if I got all As, would you be around more? I've been throwing up, Dad.
爸爸，如果我拿了全A，你会多待一会儿吗？我一直吐，爸爸。
Don't they look good, though? Don't they look good? They look all clean, and they're posture is very good. Just like you like it. Just like you like it.
它们看起来不错吧？它们看起来不错吧？看起来很整洁，姿势也很好。就像你喜欢的那样。就像你喜欢的那样。
Dad, I appreciate that you work for Federal Express and that you guys will deliver packages 24 hours a day, seven days a week, 365 days a year.
爸爸，我很感激你为联邦快递（FedEx）工作，而且你们会一年365天、一天24小时、一周七天运送包裹。
Plus you were on that island for a couple of years.
加上你在那个岛上待了几年。
But you're just never around for us! We just want to hug you for an hour.
但你就是从来没时间陪我们！我们只想拥抱你一个小时。
Oh, my god. Don't say that out loud. Don't--
噢，天哪。别大声说出来。别——
I just think that-- you just need to understand that I love you all, but I'm just very busy, just very, very busy--
我只是觉得——你只需要明白我爱你们所有人，但我只是很忙，只是非常、非常忙——
Oh, let them hug you, please.
噢，让他们拥抱你，拜托。
No, it's OK, Mom. Dad's too busy for a hug.
没，没关系，妈妈。爸爸太忙了，没空拥抱。
Thomas, look at their faces.
托马斯（Thomas），看看他们的脸。
It's OK, Mom. I don't deserve to be touched.
没关系，妈妈。我不配被触碰。
Sometimes I just send an empty package, hoping that you'll bring it back.
有时候我只是寄个空包裹，希望你会带回来。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
[观众笑声]
Dad, I just want you to know I can sense the emotional distance you're keeping. And someday I plan on replicating and furthering it.
爸爸，我只是想让你知道我能感觉到你保持的情感距离。总有一天我计划复制并进一步加深它。
All right. I'll see you all next year.
好的。明年见。
Oh. Dad.
噢。爸爸。
There he goes.
他走了。
You know what I just noticed, Dad? It's like you're inverse Santa Claus. Like, Santa Claus brings kids packages one day a year, and then you never see him again. And we only see you today, and then you bring people packages every other day.
你知道我刚才注意到什么吗，爸爸？你就像反向圣诞老人。就像，圣诞老人一年给孩子们送一次包裹，然后你就再也见不到他了。而我们今天才见到你，然后你剩下的日子里每天都给人们送包裹。
And we watch as the dad gets into his FedEx truck, and he drives off into the distance. And the kids notice that the FedEx truck flies into the air!
我们看着爸爸上了他的联邦快递卡车，开向远方。孩子们注意到联邦快递卡车飞向了空中！
[KIDS OOHING]
[孩子们的惊叹声]
Scene.
场景结束。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Our Christmas improvisers, in alphabetical order-- Scott Adsit, Mike Birbiglia, Aidy Bryant, Chris Gethard, Tami Sagher, and Sasheer Zamata.
我们的圣诞即兴演员，按字母顺序排列——斯科特·阿西特，迈克·比比利亚，艾迪·布莱恩特，克里斯·格哈德，塔米·萨格，还有萨希尔·扎马塔。
Coming up, normally responsible adults doing stuff that is wrong, just wrong, for Christmas. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，通常理智的成年人正在做一些错误的、简直是错的圣诞节事情。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, "Say Yes to Christmas," stories where people embrace possibility, try something different, because that is how you get back to the feeling of wonder that children have at Christmas when everything is so new. We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, "Oily Potter and the Gobble of Fire."
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，给你们带来关于那个主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“对圣诞节说Yes”，故事中人们拥抱可能性，尝试不同的事情，因为那是你如何找回孩子在圣诞节时那种一切都如此新鲜的神奇感觉。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“油腻波特与火焰杯”。
One of our producers, Stephanie Foo, recently discovered a Christmas tradition that's still pretty new in our country that, no kidding, brought her joy, no kidding, made the world seem like a bigger, more wonderful place to her. She has this report.
我们的一位制片人，斯蒂芬妮·富（Stephanie Foo），最近发现了一个在我们国家依然相当新鲜的圣诞传统，真的，给她带来了快乐，真的，让世界对她来说看起来变得更大、更美好了。这是她的报道。
I don't remember how I stumbled on my very first turkey explosion video. But I do remember everything else about it. The video is called "Why you should never deep fry a frozen turkey." Two firefighters are standing at the ready in front of a fire truck on a lawn somewhere. In front of them stands a large pot full of hot oil and a propane burner. Another firefighter in full gear comes out with a raw, pink turkey hanging from the end of a long stick.
我不记得我是怎么偶然发现第一个炸火鸡爆炸视频的。但我确实记得关于它的其他一切。那个视频叫“为什么你永远不应该深炸冷冻火鸡”。两名消防员在某处的草坪上，在一辆消防车前待命。在他们前面是一个盛满热油和丙烷燃烧器的大锅。另一名穿着全套装备的消防员拿着一只又生又粉的火鸡，挂在一根长棍的末端走了出来。
He lowers the turkey into the pot. It's totally submerged in oil. And then the oil bubbles and overflows, spilling everywhere, and a couple of fireballs even burst out of the pot in gusts. And then, just when you think it's over, here comes the best part.
他把火鸡放入锅里。它完全沉没在油里。然后油冒泡并溢出，到处乱洒，甚至有几个火球从锅里爆发出来。然后，当你以为结束时，最好的部分来了。
[OIL SIZZLING]
[油滋滋声]
Suddenly, an enormous, 20-foot column of fire blasts out of the pot, like Sauron himself has been conjured by way of poultry sacrifice. I watched it again and again. Then, I pulled in my coworker--
突然，一根巨大的、20英尺高的火柱从锅里喷射而出，就像萨鲁曼（Sauron）本人通过家禽献祭被召唤出来一样。我一遍又一遍地看。然后，我拉来了我的同事——
Sean, come here.
肖恩（Sean），过来。
What?
什么？
Come here.
过来。
--Sean Cole, to watch with me another time.
——肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole），和我一起再看一次。
Oh, my god.
噢，天哪。
Whoa!
哇！
Oh, wow!
噢，哇！
[LAUGHS EXCITEDLY] Oh, my god.
[兴奋的笑声] 噢，天哪。
That was great.
那太棒了。
It's just so pleasurable.
它太令人愉悦了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I saw in the "up next column" in YouTube that there were more videos like this, turkey fryer fire safety PSAs put out by fire departments across the country. We stopped counting at 150 videos. They come from Tucson to Pensacola to Danville, California, all made to demonstrate the dangers of deep frying. A lot of the videos were clearly done as segments for local TV stations.
我在YouTube的“下一个视频”栏里看到还有更多这样的视频，那是全国各地的消防部门发布的炸火鸡安全公告。我们在第150个视频时停止了计数。它们来自图森、彭萨科拉到加利福尼亚的丹维尔，全是用来演示深炸带来的危险。很多视频显然是作为当地电视台的板块制作的。
But some departments employ different theatrical methods to amp up the drama on the PSAs. Some use slow mo.
但一些部门采用了不同的戏剧手法来增加公告的戏剧性。一些使用了慢动作。
[OIL SLOWLY SIZZLING]
[慢动作的油滋滋声]
Some play epic music as you watch closeups of the pot of oil.
一些在你看特写镜头时播放史诗般的音乐。
[EPIC MUSIC PLAYING]
[史诗音乐播放]
Some spray water in the pot, obviously something you should never do with a grease fire, as it doubles the size of the flames. William Shatner even stars in one video titled "Eat, Fry, Love," created by State Farm. In it, he's playing the inept chef.
一些向锅里喷水，显然是你面对油脂火灾时永远不该做的事，因为它会让火焰翻倍。威廉·夏特纳（William Shatner）甚至主演了一个名为“吃、炸、爱”的视频，由State Farm创建。他在里面扮演那个笨手笨脚的厨师。
I want a moister, tastier turkey. I want a deep-fried turkey.
我想要一只更湿润、更美味的火鸡。我想要深炸火鸡。
And there's a dubstep remix.
还有Dubstep重混版。
[DUBSTEP MUSIC PLAYING]
[Dubstep音乐播放]
(SINGING) I want a deep-fried turkey. I want a moister, tastier turkey. I want a deep-fried turkey.
（歌唱）我想要深炸火鸡。我想要一只更湿润、更美味的火鸡。我想要深炸火鸡。
Amazingly, this was also released by State Farm.
令人惊讶的是，这也是由State Farm发布的。
(SINGING) There's a hunger. I was young and arrogant. Blinded by my hunger, I ignored safety. I want a deep-fried turkey. I want a moister, tastier, turkey.
（歌唱）有一种饥饿。我那时年轻又傲慢。被饥饿蒙蔽，我无视了安全。我想要深炸火鸡。我想要一只更湿润、更美味的火鸡。
Then there are the jackass videos--
还有那些愚蠢的视频——
[OIL SIZZLING]
[油滋滋声]
Whoa!
哇！
Oh, my god.
噢，天哪。
--where regular people, without safety gear, lower turkeys into deep fryers, sometimes from alarming heights, underneath trees and basketball hoops. Of course, there's a sub-genre here of people who actually wind up getting their decks on fire and fly into a panic. Just saying-- your average turkey fire incident injures four people-- four-- because it's a spectator sport, which is why fire departments do these videos every year.
——普通人，没有防护装备，把火鸡放入油炸锅，有时从惊人的高度，在树下和篮球架下。当然，这里有个分支种类是人们最终烧毁了甲板并陷入恐慌。我只是说——你平均每次火鸡火灾事故会炸伤四个人——四个人——因为这是一种观赏性运动，这就是为什么消防部门每年都做这些视频。
But after my seventh time watching "Why You Should Never Deep Fry a Turkey," it occurred to me that there's another reason why they do them. I noticed one of the firefighters standing in the back. He was barely suppressing a grin. I zoomed in on him, watched it again-- definitely a grin. So I called him to ask about it. His name is Lieutenant Daniel Akerman of the Escambia County Fire Rescue.
但在我第七次观看“为什么你永远不应该深炸火鸡”之后，我想到他们这样做的另一个原因。我注意到其中一名站在后面的消防员。他几乎掩盖不住他的咧嘴笑。我放大看了看他，又看了一遍——绝对是咧嘴笑。所以我打电话问他这件事。他的名字是埃斯坎比亚县消防救援队的丹尼尔·阿克曼（Daniel Akerman）中尉。
Definitely one of the highlights of being in the office. When you actually drop that turkey, you're not 100% sure how it's going to come out.
绝对是在办公室里最棒的时刻之一。当你真的放下那只火鸡，你并不百分之百确定它会发生什么。
Here's some of the guys from the Fargo Fire Department. They have one of my favorite videos.
这是来自法戈（Fargo）消防局的一些伙计。他们有我最喜欢的视频之一。
Hi.
嗨。
Hello.
你好。
Hi.
嗨。
Do all of you guys like setting turkeys on fire?
你们所有人喜欢点燃火鸡吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yeah, you're doing the opposite of what you're supposed to be doing. You're supposed to be putting out fire, but you get to start one.
对，你们在做你们本该做的相反的事。你们本该灭火，但你们却能点燃一团。
Yeah, it's fun.
对，这很好玩。
What's your favorite part about the flaming turkey tradition?
关于火鸡着火的传统，你最喜欢的部分是什么？
Making as big a fireball as you can.
尽可能制造一个巨大的火球。
Oh, yeah.
噢，对。
And they're good at it. Fargo's fireball is two stories tall.
他们很擅长。法戈的火球有两层楼高。
[FIRE HISSING]
[火的嘶嘶声]
Your explosion is huge.
你们的爆炸太大了。
Yeah.
对。
What is happening where you are able to get it to be so big?
到底发生了什么，让你们能弄得这么大？
Sure. Well, we're not following any of the safety recommendations to get it to be that dramatic to show people absolute worst case what can happen.
当然。嗯，为了展示最糟糕的情况，我们没遵循任何安全建议来让它变得那么具有戏剧性。
Did you guys practice?
你们练习过吗？
Yeah. We did find out through practice that the more oil we put in the pot, by filling it to the top, made the fireball as big as possible.
对。我们通过练习确实发现，通过把油加满，直到锅顶，能让火球尽可能大。
Quick science lesson. These frozen turkeys are filled with ice. Ice, of course, is water. And water does not mix with oil. So when the turkeys hit the oil, that ice turns to water turns to steam, which pushes the oil out of the pot, and when that hits the flame underneath, boom.
科学小课堂。这些冷冻火鸡里充满了冰。冰，当然，是水。而水不和油混合。所以当火鸡撞击油时，冰变成水变成蒸汽，它把油从锅里推出来，当蒸汽接触到底部的火焰时，砰。
So your basic turkey frying don'ts are as follows. One, don't put in a frozen turkey. You should thaw your turkey 24 hours for every five pounds. That's three whole days for a 15-pounder. Two, don't put in a wet turkey or a too-big turkey. Three, don't overfill the pot with oil or overheat the oil. Four, do not do this inside. And lastly, most fire departments would tell you the most important don't is just please, don't deep fry a turkey at all.
所以你基本的炸火鸡禁忌如下。第一，不要放入冷冻火鸡。你应该每五磅解冻火鸡24小时。15磅的火鸡需要整整三天。第二，不要放入湿火鸡或太大的火鸡。第三，不要把油加得太满或过度加热油。第四，不要在室内做这个。最后，大多数消防部门会告诉你最重要的禁忌就是求你，根本不要去深炸火鸡。
Fargo double did all the don'ts. Like, while some firefighters heat their demonstration pots to 350, Fargo took theirs to 700. The pot of oil is obviously already in flames and overflowing before the turkey gets anywhere near it, like an active volcano.
法戈（Fargo）把所有的禁忌都做了。比如，虽然一些消防员将演示锅加热到350度，法戈把它们加热到了700度。油锅在火鸡接近它之前显然就已经着火并溢出了，就像一座活火山。
I managed to find the first turkey fire video from 2002. It's called "Turkey Fryer-- Your Dinner for Your Life?" It's hosted by this earnest guy in a hardhat named John Drengenberg, who was not in it for the fun, the fame, or the fireballs. I asked him, is he proud of being the originator of this new holiday tradition, the turkey explosion video?
我设法找到了2002年的第一个火鸡火灾视频。它叫“油炸锅——你的晚餐还是你的命？”它由一个戴安全帽、名叫约翰·德伦根伯格（John Drengenberg）的真诚家伙主持，他不是为了好玩、出名或火球才做这个的。我问他，作为这个新节日传统——火鸡爆炸视频的鼻祖，他感到自豪吗？
OK, first of all, I'm an engineer. So they aren't explosions.
好的，首先，我是个工程师。所以它们不是爆炸。
Oh, OK. I'm sorry.
噢，好的。抱歉。
OK.
好的。
So what would the appropriate terminology be?
那合适的术语应该是什么？
Flaming oil is being expelled from the turkey fryer.
燃烧的油正在从火鸡油炸锅中喷出。
So how do you feel about being the originator of the tradition of flaming turkey oil videos?
所以，作为燃烧火鸡油视频传统的鼻祖，你感觉如何？
It's not unusual. It's in keeping with our mission of alerting people to safety issues.
这不罕见。这符合我们提醒人们注意安全问题的使命。
Sure. But you know, outside of the mission, what does it make you feel?
当然。但你知道，在使命之外，它让你感觉到了什么？
Like we've accomplished a goal of alerting people to the dangers.
就像我们已经完成了提醒人们注意危险的目标。
John works for Underwriters Laboratories. They test products to make sure they're safe. I just walked over to the part of our office that has a toaster and a coffee grinder, and I found UL logos on everything, even the light bulbs. And so when John started testing turkey deep fryers at UL in 2002, he found them so egregiously dangerous and prone to failure that they put out a press release calling for stronger turkey fryer guidelines. And because most people don't read press releases, he figured they had to make a PSA informing people about those dangers, too, because John sees danger around us all the time. And he does not think the turkey videos are sensationalistic in the slightest.
约翰为Underwriters Laboratories（UL）工作。他们测试产品以确保它们安全。我刚才走到我们办公室有烤面包机和咖啡研磨机的地方，我发现UL标志在一切上，甚至灯泡上。所以当约翰在2002年在UL开始测试深炸锅时，他发现它们非常危险且容易失效，于是他们发布了一份新闻稿呼吁加强炸火鸡准则。因为大多数人不读新闻稿，他认为他们必须制作一个公共服务广告告知人们那些危险，因为约翰随时随地都能看到危险。他一点也不认为火鸡视频是耸人听闻的。
I think we tried to show the reality. Even if you're using it correctly, and a dog runs by it or it could bump into the stand and knock the turkey fryer down, which would cause some very serious burns on a pet, as well as a child.
我想我们尝试展示的是现实。即使你正确使用它，如果有一条狗跑过去，或者它撞到了架子并把火鸡炸锅弄倒了，那会导致宠物以及孩子严重烧伤。
Do your friends and family ever-- are you, like, calling them out and being like, please don't do that. And are they like, oh, come on. Just chill out about it. It's fine.
你的朋友和家人有没有——你有没有叫住他们，说，求求你们别那样做。而他们说，噢，拜托。冷静点。没事的。
Well, the fact is they call me Mr. Safety. And I've actually cut a cord off my mother-in-law's fan, because it was so-- the cord was all ratty. And you know, it was cracked. The insulation was cracked, and there was bare wire on it. And I said, you can't plug this fan in. And she said, well, I need it. It keeps me cool. And I said, it's not good for you. So I unplugged it myself and I cut the cord off so she--
嗯，事实是他们叫我“安全先生”。我甚至切断了我岳母风扇的电线，因为它太——电线很破旧。你知道，它裂开了。绝缘层裂开了，裸露着金属线。我说，你不能插这个风扇。她说，我需要它。它让我凉快。我说，这不安全。所以我自己拔掉它并切断了电线，所以她——
Why didn't you just take the fan?
为什么你不直接拿走风扇？
Well, I could have done that.
嗯，我本来可以那么做的。
So you're a bit of a worrier.
所以你是个爱操心的人。
Well, I've got a bit of experience in the field of product safety.
嗯，我在产品安全领域有一点经验。
Do you have any other really important holiday cautionary tips for us before I let you go?
在让你走之前，你还有什么对我们很重要的节日提醒吗？
Make sure your smoke alarm is working. Make sure you water your tree. You have to run your hand along on  the branches in the tree lot to make sure you don't end up with a handful of needles. If you do, the tree is too dry. You should never bring it home. There are statistics you can get, by the way, Stephanie, from places like the Consumer Product Safety Commission on just how many people are injured each year while decorating. I mean, it's like 18,000 people hurt themselves decorating.
确保你的烟雾报警器工作正常。确保给树浇水。你必须在树场沿着树枝滑动手，以确保你最终不会只抓到一把针叶。如果那样，树太干了。你永远不该带它回家。顺便说一句，斯蒂芬妮，你可以从像消费品安全委员会这样的地方获取数据，关于每年有多少人在装饰时受伤。我是说，大概有18000人在装饰时弄伤了自己。
Oh, my god.
噢，天哪。
Yeah, we could talk for two hours, if you'd like, about cautionary tips.
对，如果你愿意，我们可以聊两个小时关于预防措施。
Jeez, well, why even celebrate at all?
天呐，那为什么还要过节？
Oh, that's-- we're not grinches here. We just want to keep people safe. That's our mission, whatever your holiday. And it's not just Christmas. It's Hanukkah. It's Kwanzaa, all of that. And all of those holidays, by the way, use candles.
噢，那——我们不是格林奇（圣诞怪杰）。我们只是想保护人们的安全。那是我们的使命，无论你过什么节日。而且不仅仅是圣诞节。它是光明节。它是宽扎节（Kwanzaa），所有的这些。顺便说一句，所有这些节日都使用蜡烛。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
You want go into candles? You ready for candles? Can you handle it?
你想聊聊蜡烛吗？准备好聊蜡烛了吗？你能应付吗？
John suggests that in lieu of candles this year, try using LED tealights instead. And if you think that's too drastic, please go to YouTube right now and type in the words "Christmas tree fires." And then help John have a Merry Christmas. Go water your tree.
约翰建议今年用LED茶蜡代替蜡烛。如果你觉得那太极端，请现在去YouTube输入单词“圣诞树火灾”。然后帮约翰过个圣诞快乐。去浇树吧。
Stephanie Foo is one of the producers of our program. We checked, by the way, with the Consumer Product Safety Commission and learned that on average, there were only about 13-- 13-- turkey fryer-related incidents a year, which means one of two things, OK? Either number one, the hundreds of turkey fryer fire videos online are unnecessary. Or, number two, the hundreds of turkey fryer fire videos online are working.
斯蒂芬妮·富是我们节目的制片人之一。顺便说一句，我们和消费品安全委员会核实后得知，平均每年只有大约13起——13起——与油炸锅相关的事故，这意味着两件事之一，好吗？要么第一，网上的数百个油炸锅火灾视频是不必要的。要么第二，网上的数百个油炸锅火灾视频是有效的。
Act Three, "The First Noelle." Andre is six years old. And this is his first Christmas with, you know, Santa and presents and the whole deal. And already, it's been like one incredible thing after another. Till recently, he and his little brother, Luke, who's four, had been in an orphanage in the Democratic Republic of Congo. And in the orphanage, Christmas was not much of a thing.
第三幕，“第一首Noelle”。安德烈（Andre）六岁。这是他第一个圣诞节，你知道，有圣诞老人、礼物和全套东西。而且这已经是接连不断的神奇体验了。直到最近，他和弟弟卢克（Luke）四岁，还住在刚果民主共和国的一家孤儿院。在孤儿院，圣诞节并不算什么。
But now they're living outside Seattle, where it definitely is a thing. Weeks ago, Christmas lights started popping up.
但现在他们住在西雅图郊外，那里圣诞节意义重大。几周前，圣诞灯饰开始出现了。
And they would point to that and say, Mom, Mom, look at that. And so we started to explain, yeah, that's for Christmas. It's to celebrate Christmas.
他们会指着灯说，妈妈，妈妈，看那个。所以我们就开始解释，对，那是为圣诞节。那是为了庆祝圣诞节。
This is Jennefer. She and her husband adopted Andre and Luke.
这是詹妮弗（Jennefer）。她和丈夫收养了安德烈和卢克。
And then we drove through the neighborhood, just with the purpose of looking for lights, they were just non-stop. It didn't matter how big the light display was. They were amazed.
然后我们开车穿过街区，专门为了看灯，他们简直停不下来。灯饰多大都不重要。他们太惊讶了。
Wow! Wow!
哇！哇！
But look at Snoopy!
但看史努比（Snoopy）！
Bye!
再见！
Snoopy!
史努比！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
This is obviously from a recording they made on that drive. Jennefer and her husband also have two little girls, seven and five, who you can hear on the recording.
这显然是他们在那次车程中录下的录音。詹妮弗和丈夫还有两个小女孩，七岁和五岁，你可以在录音中听到她们的声音。
[KIDS OOHING AND AHHING]
[孩子们的惊叹声]
Do you see two of them in the [INAUDIBLE]?
你们能看到[听不清]里的那两个吗？
Whoa.
哇。
And no one wanted to go home. They just couldn't get enough of it.
而且没人想回家。他们就是看不够。
Whoa.
哇。
It's been kind of a crash course since the boys arrived in the States. They just got here this November. They'd heard some Christmas basics before. This adoption process has taken three years. And Jennefer lived with the boys in Kinshasa for most of this year, and she talked about Christmas a little bit with the boys. But you know, if you think about it, it is a lot to cover. With her girls, you know, from the time that they could speak, they were basically living in a world with Christmas and Santa and all that, but with the boys--
自从男孩们来到美国，这简直是一场速成课程。他们今年11月才到。他们以前听说过一些圣诞基础知识。这个收养过程花了三年。詹妮弗今年大部分时间都和男孩们住在金沙萨，她和男孩们谈了一些关于圣诞节的事。但你知道，如果你想想看，要涵盖的内容实在太多了。对于她的女孩，你知道，从她们会说话开始，她们基本上就生活在有圣诞节、圣诞老人等等的世界里，但对于这些男孩——
It must have been strange for you. You really have to start at the beginning and walk through a whole lot of stuff. And it's like, there's reindeer, and there's like this whole-- it's really like kind of a lot to explain, right?
这对你来说一定很奇怪。你真的得从零开始，走过一大堆东西。就像，有驯鹿，有这个整个——解释起来真的很多，对吧？
Right, yeah. We had to hit a lot of basics. Who is Rudolph? Who is even Santa? I mean, the fact that we had a Christmas tree in our house, oh. And even that we went to pick out a Christmas tree and then tied this tree onto our car-- you know, the little things that we just do every year so we don't really think about it as strange. But when you were a kid and you see a tree tied to a car, or you're tying it to your own car, he'd be like, "Why? What are they doing to the tree? Why are they putting it on the roof?" And we opened up the sunroof while he was in there, just the window part so he could see it. And he just stared at it in awe.
对，是的。我们不得不抓基础。鲁道夫是谁？圣诞老人又是谁？我是说，我们在房子里有棵圣诞树，噢。甚至我们去挑选圣诞树，然后把树绑在我们的车上——你知道，那些我们每年都做所以并不觉得奇怪的小事。但当你还是个孩子，看到一棵树绑在车上，或者你把它绑在自己的车上时，他会想，“为什么？他们在对树做什么？为什么他们要把它放在车顶？”他在车里时我们打开了天窗，只是窗户那部分，好让他能看见。他只是敬畏地盯着它看。
One of the recordings you made is of, I guess, Andre saying over and over, "Are you kidding me, guys? Are you kidding me, guys? Are you kidding me, guys?" What's that about?
你做的一段录音中，我猜是安德烈一遍又一遍地说，“你们在开玩笑吗，伙计们？你们在开玩笑吗，伙计们？你们在开玩笑吗，伙计们？”那是什么情况？
Yeah, he kept opening new ornaments and seeing a new ornament. We have a tradition in our family that we hang up an ornament with a picture of each child each year. So they were both really excited to see their own faces on ornaments as they hung them up. So--
对，他不停地拆开新饰品，看到一个新饰品。我们家族有个传统，每年悬挂一个带有每个孩子照片的饰品。所以他们看到饰品挂上去时上面有自己的脸，都非常兴奋。所以——
Are you kidding me, guys? Are you kidding me, guys? Are you kidding me, guys?
你们在开玩笑吗，伙计们？你们在开玩笑吗，伙计们？你们在开玩笑吗，伙计们？
His English is so new, so he usually uses that when he sees something that he really likes.
他的英语太新了，所以他通常在看到自己真正喜欢的东西时会用那句话。
Growing up in the orphanage, not only did they not have ornaments and trees and Santa, they didn't get presents-- not for Christmas, not for birthdays.
在孤儿院长大，他们不仅没有饰品、树和圣诞老人，他们甚至没有礼物——无论是圣诞节还是生日。
Yeah, you know, they didn't really have belongings before. Everything was shared at the orphanage.
对，你知道，他们之前没有真正的个人物品。孤儿院里一切都是共享的。
Neither of them ever asked anybody for a gift or picked out a present to give to somebody. That's all new.
他们中没人要求过别人给礼物，或者挑一份礼物给别人。那全是新鲜事。
Of course, Christmas is just one of the new things that they're experiencing in their new lives in this country. The orphanage that they lived in was on the outskirts of Kinshasa and didn't have electricity or running water. Even going to a store was a new experience for the boys when they joined Jennefer's family.
当然，圣诞节只是他们在国家新生活中体验到的新鲜事物之一。他们居住的孤儿院在金沙萨郊外，没有电和自来水。甚至去商店对男孩们来说也是加入詹妮弗家庭后的全新体验。
Everything's amazing right now, so it's not hard to believe that Santa comes and brings you gifts. That's just one of the many things.
现在一切都很神奇，所以不难相信圣诞老人来了并给你带礼物。那只是清单上众多事情之一。
Compared with the incredibleness of, you know, living in a house with water that comes out of faucets, and a play room, and a family, Santa Claus, the idea of Santa Claus, that's just really just like one more thing on the list, right? A guy flies in with a sleigh in the middle of the night with a bag of presents? Why not? It's all kind of amazing if we just let ourselves see it that way.
相比于生活在有自来水龙头、游戏室和家庭的房子里那种不可思议，圣诞老人，圣诞老人的想法，那真的只是列表上的又一件事情，对吧？一个家伙半夜带着雪橇和一袋礼物飞来？为什么不呢？如果我们让自己那样看它，这一切都很神奇。
Well, our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar, with Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Robyn Semien, Alyssa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our editor is Joel Lovell. Julie Snyder is our editorial consultant. Our technical director is Mr. Matt Tierney, who recorded our improv show this week.
好了，我们的节目今天由乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）制作，佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德拉明（Neil Drumming）、斯蒂芬妮·富、查娜·乔菲-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、艾丽莎·希普（Alyssa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）参与。我们的高级制片人是布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）。我们的编辑是乔尔·洛维尔（Joel Lovell）。朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）是我们的编辑顾问。我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）先生，他录制了本周的即兴表演秀。
Production help from Lily Sullivan. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson is our business operations manager. Elna Baker scouts stories for our show and helped produce our night of improv. Kimberly Henderson is our office coordinator. Research help from Christopher [INAUDIBLE]. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
莉莉·沙利文（Lily Sullivan）提供制作帮助。赛斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康顿（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是我们的业务运营经理。埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）为节目寻找故事并协助制作了我们的即兴表演之夜。金伯利·亨德森（Kimberly Henderson）是我们的办公室协调员。克里斯托弗[听不清]提供研究帮助。达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）和罗布·格迪斯（Rob Geddis）提供音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who gives me regular critiques of our program. And you know, it always seems he's a little confused by the show.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org。节目由公共广播交换中心（PRX）分发到公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢节目联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生，他定期对我们的节目进行批评。而且你知道，他似乎总是对节目感到有点困惑。
(SINGING OFF-KEY) What do you mean? What do you mean by what you're saying?
（跑调歌唱）什么意思？你刚才说的话是什么意思？
I'm Ira Glass. Happy holidays, everybody. We'll be back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。大家节日快乐。我们下周将带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。